so
hopefully I haven't forgotten too much
of what I wanted to say
um
and I may bounce around a little
but um I did say it might sound like ego
and me me me and
i i n
ope but I'm just telling you my story to
get to we all have a story inside of us
the main point of making this series of
films
is we all have to make decisions we all
have to commit
we have to commit to liking things we
don't like at times we have to commit to
working in places we don't like to work
um
even training you know you're sometimes
end up training with people
that you wouldn't want to train with a
second time
after meeting cytosensei in New Zealand
I built my first dojo
I decided that um
after spending
I don't know if it was a week or four
days it was you know it felt like
eternity and it was wonderful
you told me to buy as much film as I
could I had a cine camera myself
and all photographs were banned
of any kind and all filming was banned
at any time he said he'd just retired
from the railway
this was his first seminar he was really
pleased with such a large attendance
well if 60p was a large attendance for
for an eighth then
but but those were the days you know he
was he was a very humble
student of her Sensei and all he wanted
to do was keep oh since his Aikido pure
he developed the anti-carter of the 31
and I essentially asked him to put the
anti-carter to our senses 31 Carter
so he said I can't change the Carter or
anything no sense you taught me but I
can add and develop my own weapons
but I will not change anything that I've
since he gave us and he decided that he
wasn't going to be a spiritual teacher
in any form
for his students to follow
he was gonna he was going to set his
life to teaching a sense his basic
Aikido techniques
um
and he said he couldn't remember them
all but the ones he could and to believe
me what was hundreds and hundreds
um that was his quest in life
so I I went back home I built a dojo and
he said to me
um by gay
have a Ken and Joe put mirrors on the
wall
um
and I think later on
they advised it to get the tamanucci as
well but that wasn't that particular
time and that was in I believe February
1982.
after a few
um and then he he the student that I met
in New Zealand
was at his I don't know he had
definitely a year if not longer in iwama
azuchadeshi he'd got his first Dan
he was a massive guy very nice and such
a sense he said before you go back to
Switzerland I want you to divert to
England and teach Tony so that was
another reason why I wanted to get a um
a dojo ready
and I had the premises this large garage
and a showroom and above it there was a
spare area and I converted it into a
permanent dojo
he he came he taught me and um
I I learned a great deal from him
Andre and I went on to Switzerland to
meet him and
and it was the start of another Journey
the
the body you may know this I don't know
like I said earlier in the film there's
three of us doing the 31 Carter and even
though we were all doing the same
positions we all look different in the
way we
showed it through our bodies
um
so
after six months
I was finding that my body was like a
car running out of fuel
I started to doubt if my memory of what
he told taught me
was in my head or really did he teach me
so I would go on to I don't know how I
found out now to be honest but I would
find out where he was in somewhere in
the world
and every six months after that first
meeting I would travel somewhere in the
world
I didn't go back to New Zealand but I
went to America several times and I met
some really nice people in the Oakland
dojo
and again I won't mention names but
there was a there used to be about
around about 60 people on the mat every
night in this dojo
and it was it was an amazing teacher
sadly he didn't turn out so good in the
end
for the public but we won't go into that
now but the attendance was excellent and
I met many many of the top teachers that
were in America today
we became friends because I'd go back
every summer to the summer camp and
because cytosensi would go there regular
so that was one of the
the plan six months and the other one
when I was running out of fuel again I
would find
another place for him to go
could be Germany Italy I remember
one particular one where I went to the
USA and some new people invited him in
New Jersey
and he was doing book signing
I didn't have one of his books with me
at the time I had the book of five rings
one of the few books that I've ever read
this was in
1983 so it was a year on from when I
first met him
and he was doing the book signing and he
was signing the books with a pen
stamping them
and then he didn't he hadn't
um
maybe he was in this sitting in this
very small little closet
signing away his books
and when he saw my face he put the pen
to one side he got out his calligraphy I
mean I'll call it a pen but obviously
it's a brush
we've got a pen I only had this book so
I handed him this book
he
put his signature the date and his stamp
in book gave it back to me
the next person in the line was passing
to think that he was gonna get something
special since he put his calligraphy
set away got his pen and carried on
signing
so I'd like to Just Bounce about a bit
here with my thoughts
in New Zealand
I went there and I was welcomed I'd come
from the other side of the world
in fact a sense he took me everywhere he
went told me as much as he could about
Aikido and no sensei
um
but I was it's you know a very small
Ford Escort I was invited to be with him
all the time
there was a driver who was Keith Hartley
who had invited
Scentsy
who I became friends with as well
and he was a yorkshireman that moved to
New Zealand
sadly passed away by now
and
I liked him a lot
inside your Sensei so Keith was a driver
so I just said she was in the passenger
seat
Andre was in the back and I was next to
him
it's like I said since he said as I told
you
that I must be there every time wherever
he goes so all the sightseeing and all
the things that we've done
we done together
and uh I don't when I look back on it I
mean what an honor what what an
experience
and you know I was a bit gullible
because to me
um it just seems so easy as if you know
you went on holiday with your best
friend it was just no
nothing demanding of me nothing
you know just we seem to he seemed to be
at ease with me straight away and
you know he was happy to talk and it was
if me and the Dashie was of an equal
friendship
but I know it's the people
start to not like me on the course
they didn't like it because I was
allowed my cine camera
and since he's saying buy as much film
as you can afford Tony and you'd be
there in front of me and you just keep
filming me
well the people who are hosting here
weren't even allowed to take a snapshot
unless he said that they could take
photos that was mainly in the evenings
for special presentations
so I started getting a disc lock people
disliking me
through no fault of my own
New Jersey
him signing my book and the only person
to have one signed with a string of
people in the line
with his calligraphy set
and I know it is me me me again but I'm
just trying to paint the picture of my
experience with cytosensi
you you grow better roses than me he
said when he stayed at my house in the
village of all
he came with Stan planning
isn't she he's a
judeshi at the time
and
we're standing in the garden and he's
saying go and get pen and paper
Tony I want to draw how the Japanese
family designs their Garden on their
family
this made me realize that there's more
to this master than Aikido and of course
that's like he took us all we think
about is Aikido Aikido Aikido but you
know here's a man who's got a life
and here's a man talking on this camera
who's got a knife
two children
um a mortgage
a business that had grown
and he came and stayed with me in 1989
June 89 it was
so the years had been rolling by I'd
been seeing him twice a year every year
somewhere in the world
to how many Italy Switzerland
America
um you know it just went on and on in
the UK Scotland
um
Hillingdon University came to
for 19 years
I saw him twice a year somewhere in the
world
it wouldn't matter where it was
he gave me my
first second and third down akikaya
because he said well you should you
should have it because I'm like a guy
he didn't like the
um style and the homo dojo
but the ikikai is something separate
that was organized
it's it's it's an office within the
hombu building in Tokyo
and the office is the ikikai so it's a
bit like
let's say somebody rents an office out
of a tall building well the building's
got different floors in it and there's
Aikido being trained and they're
training in the style of the Honda dojos
it's a flowering style and um some very
good quality teachers there and a very
nice style to watch and also train and
I've I've trained in this style as other
styles and I've still
personally prefer
it warmer to you
only because it seems to work as
effective it works
my student one of my students a third
down said
you can't teach your students all the
time
for that one time that they might be
attacked in the streets I mean why would
they spend year after year
for that one time they paranoid they're
going to be attacked there's got to be
more to it than that
and I had to agree with them
I do it because I enjoy it it gives me a
balance
but I can't do something
that doesn't work or else that wouldn't
be me it would be it would be like false
so let's say yes I'm doing this
technique it works because my master is
not only
said so but he's told me that it comes
from a Scentsy
I've used it in different countries
I remember going first to Russia in I
believe 1994
all these strong Russians big some
strong some scars bent noses tattoos all
sorts
they would test you they you would have
to have your best form
and it's never let me down so my Aikido
from my master teaching me works
so once that part's out the way
you can just enjoy your art guy you can
enjoy the cardiovascular work that you
do you can enjoy the pain the endurance
of being able to go through the pain
when you're in sweaty water and you
think that it feels like your knees are
bleeding
you think to yourself if I give up now
then I'll look
bad and that will hurt my ego so you
keep going a little bit longer and you
the pain is getting so great that the
technique becomes
the last thing on your mind you're doing
the technique because the teacher's
watching you
but all you're worried about is the pain
in your knees I'm worried about the
amount of blood that will be coming out
and how you haven't got any bandages to
stop the blood
so it ends up with poor little me is
more important than the Aikido
so
if you train long enough
you're going to go through
the fun
the pleasure the joy
you're also going to go through the pain
you're going to go through some really
painful hurtful times
I remember being in America I was going
there for two weeks
the Scentsy thought that I went there to
test him being a big strong person
I didn't know that's what he thought
so he done the most powerful Nikki on Me
on the first day
I couldn't feel
this little finger and this part of the
hand
pull this part of the hand I couldn't
feel for the next two weeks it was numb
it killed it
we went to a party one night
and I had to confront him even though
you you don't talk to the sense unless
they talk to you this is how strict
it was in those days
you had to know your place
there am I
running a
multi-million pound business back home
bringing up a family with all the
concerns that that brings running your
children to parties and all the things
that see their friends and all the
things you have to do 24 7. run a
business employ staff who have got all
sorts of problems because I believe I
was up to about five staff then might
not see how much you get
that's five problems adding to your own
personal problems
a mortgage a moved house a tough a
couple of times I think then
um couldn't buy a house so I had to rent
one because I'd take it on the Large
Garage
so it's not a poor little me it was what
I chose to do is to watch what I wanted
but I'm giving you the picture that I
was fanatical about Aikido
50 years on I'm still that fanatic
I've done all sorts of things that if
you've listened to my other films you'll
know
but I'm still here
and it's because I gave my word to sight
of Scentsy that I would continue his
work throughout Europe and try and show
the best I could go I could show
at times I get people queering my Aikido
and they say why are you doing the
identity doing it
so because I've got so many books I've
got these old cine films still
I can look back
sometimes it'll take me a day or two to
find the exact picture the exact
point
that they're questioning
I'm gonna they say touch wood
I've always
can prove what I'm doing is what
cytosensi taught me that some period in
those 20 years
19 20 years you know
so
if I'm wrong I'm wrong and when I'm
teaching sometimes I make a mistake
a cytosense he said he saw a sense and
make loads of mistakes over his 24 years
he said he often makes mistakes but
that's because we're human and we might
just
get it wrong a few times
it doesn't happen so often thankfully
nowadays but we get it wrong
but if we get it wrong own up and say
that's wrong
if you chose something
that's incorrect research it if you're
wrong and it has been created in your
head
tell the students sorry I must have made
that one up it must have felt good but
I've researched yeah I can't find my
version anywhere it must be wrong that's
my advice to you as a teacher or student
because even being a student you will be
teaching others
around you
who want to have more knowledge
thank you for your time
I will continue this journey
with you
shortly